[Music]
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends they have baseballs on them i
see that no not those nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
entertainment system
no nintendo on my house i second that
looks like a no-go on nintendo
i needed a christmas miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowl was inaudible okay does it really
matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s
[Music]
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one anyway you huddled masters
on a play
what have you brought me
untraceable cash money
[Music]
one thing became clear i needed to get
my own
this is bigger than christmas
[Music]
this is our vietnam i don't think that
means what you think it means i have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble
sometimes during christmas just when you
think that all hope is lost something
magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes suddenly one
woman punched a grandma right in the
throat
same family too are you making all this
up no no no way
did you guys hear in the race selling
contests first prize is a brand new
nintendo entertainment
i'm gonna system you
hold on
[Music]
there are no rules
[Music]
that nintendo's mine
what do you want to buy a reef
ma this kid thinks your wreath sucks
video games
have been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
red dog this is bluebird this is rainbow
one what happened to red dog i changed
it well let's change names now this is
millennium falcon super cool
love it rated pg
[Music]
you